Your mission is to destroy every trace of
something known only as project starfish starfish
is a slang term for a butthole think there's
any connection we're gonna die i hope so
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
suicide squad movie review what year is this is it
2021 or is it 2016. also explain where this fits
in the timeline how it's connected to the events
of the first suicide squad movie because it isn't
a reboot but there is a lot of the cast from the
first movie that came back for this so i'll also
explain how it connects to the other dc eu movies
the timeline of the justice league snyder cut
all that stuff if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos once
the movie does fully come out and gets released
everywhere i will do a full breakdown in easter
eggs video post credit scene videos all that stuff
yes there are two different post credits scenes
so make sure you stay through the entire credits
but overall the movie is just a huge upgrade
you've probably been seeing most of the reactions
going crazy over it there's actually a lot of
early screenings they've been trying to do for
it so there's a chance that you actually might
be able to see it a couple days early for free
overall it was a very low bar that this movie
had to clear in order to be better than the
first movie so even if it had just been an okay
movie it still would have been a big step up
the way they treat the continuity of the timeline
the idea is that this is just the next big threat
that amanda waller has to deal with and some of
the members from that last team are either back
in prison to be used again for the new mission
like captain boomerang or harley quinn or they're
still working together like rick flack so it's
just the next version of the team with a couple
of survivors from the last team generally i would
say the events of the movie take place after the
justice league snyder cut in after the birds of
prey movie in the way that everybody is supposed
to be a bad guy during the suicide squad movies
like they're all either anti-heroes or really
despicable villains it's all just shades of
different types of villains there's a huge
threat that amanda waller has to take care of a
big problem in the idea that the government the
us government the military is low-key kind of also
responsible for creating the problem themselves
in the first place but a while ago james gunn
was explaining how he wound up at dc making
a movie after spending so much time at marvel
and he said that they literally told him that
he could do any movie that he wanted with maybe
the exception of batman because i think at that
time they were still in the process of spinning
up on the matt reeves batman movie but literally
any characters that he wanted any movie any title
that he wanted he could do anything the reason why
he said he chose the suicide squad to do is one
because he had grown up a huge fan of the original
john ostrander run if you are a big comic book fan
you probably spotted him in a lot of the earlier
trailers john ostrander got his own stan lee
cameo style moment he's the doctor in bell rev who
implants all the exploding chips in the brains for
amanda waller but two james gunn also said that
he felt like one of the biggest issues today with
comic book movies big superhero movies in general
is that most the time it feels like there are no
stakes you always feel like the characters are
wearing plot armor they're never going to die
because they can't die they're the heroes they
kind of tried to buck that trend a little with
avengers infinity war and avengers end game in
the marvel universe not counting the characters
that show up in alternate timelines alternate
realities everybody looking at loki right now all
the loki's but the suicide squad just as a story
as a property was the perfect solution to that
problem it's literally built into the dna of the
story that a bunch of them always wind up getting
killed off often in hilarious and gruesome ways
they kind of tried to do that a little bit during
the first movie but i feel like this new suicide
squad movie really delivers on that promise like
dc says oh you can kill off any characters that
you want and james gunn says hold my beer you
may have seen in all the early marketing in the
last couple of years the tagline was don't get
too attached as in most of these characters are
probably going to die i won't get into big
spoilers in this video about who does wind up
living and dying but if you watch the trailers
you can make some pretty good guesses based on
who shows up at the beginning of the trailer and
who does not show up at the end of the trailers
that being said there are still a few characters
that are wearing some plot armor during this movie
like harley quinn clearly because dc has plans
for a lot more harley quinn movies there's always
going to be one or two characters you're like
there's no way they're ever going to kill that
person off even when zack snyder killed superman
off everyone's like they're definitely bringing
superman back there's no way that that sticks
but james gunn basically takes the suicide squad
and does with them what he did with the first
guardians of the galaxy movie getting you to
care about a bunch of really really despicable
people but the suicide squad movie is rated r
so it's just a much more hardcore version of that
so this time instead of getting you to care about
a talking tree and a talking raccoon it's a
talking shark wearing pants and a giant weasel
and in the same way that groot really did make
guardians of the galaxy for a lot of people
king shark is definitely one of the standout
champs from this movie obviously they're very
different characters the tone of suicide squad is
very different from guardians of the galaxy but
it's the same type of energy there very down and
dirty group of rogues if you couldn't tell either
king shark is voiced by sylvester stallone yes he
was starhawk during the guardians of the galaxy 2
there are a couple of notable marvel guardians
of the galaxy actors that are in this movie
james gunn's brother sean gunn plays the weasel
character the funny connection there is that yes
he does play craglin you see his face on screen
but he's also the stand-in for rocket raccoon on
set when they're filming so he went from playing
a tiny fur covered creature to a giant one
weasel is nothing like rocket or groot in
the movie though what you see from him in
the trailers like the jokes that they use him
for that's basically what you get from him he's
there to be super weird kind of gross and really
really hilarious overall the movie just in general
was plotted out and designed to feel like a dirty
dozen type of war movie there's no ring of garbage
in the sky like the first movie they successfully
fixed a lot of the issues the people had with the
main villains from that last suicide squad movie
like i said though true to form everyone in this
movie is a bad guy so to speak it's just that
some of them are way way worse but most of them
are criminals serving near-life sentences for
crimes against humanity like bloodsport for
instance idris elba's character is in prison for
shooting henry cavill's superman with a kryptonite
bullet and putting him in critical condition in
the big roll call that you see at the beginning
of the trailers when there are a billion different
characters yes a couple of them are written to be
douchebags on purpose but like i said don't get
too attached they have funny ways of dealing with
a really really terrible characters amanda waller
if you've read any of her comic book stories she's
a really despicable character but you do get where
she's coming from and she was pretty decent in the
first suicide squad movie i never had any issues
with her portrayal or the way that they wrote her
so viola davis is fantastic as amanda waller in
this new movie she gives you exactly what you
need from that character their literal big bad as
starro as you've seen from all the trailers but as
funny as it sounds they actually do a good job of
humanizing him even though he is a giant starfish
from outer space you do sympathize with starro
despite the fact that he is the original justice
league villain from their very first team up i
don't want to get into huge spoilers about what
they're doing with him during the movie but the
idea is that as bad as he is he is not the worst
thing in the movie one of the other big villains
is peter capaldi's thinker who is a huge upgrade
from the flash tv show version of the thinker
for anyone that watched that season as you can
see he's designed around the new 52 devoe version
of the thinker with the electrodes sticking out
of his head peter capaldi is an amazing actor and
even though most of you know him from doctor who
really it feels like he's got more of his malcolm
tucker energy in this from the thick of it
just a really awful really despicable character
that you enjoy watching there are so many huge
actors in this movie but they do a good job of
utilizing them like i said it's all in service
of that tagline don't get too attached in the idea
that amanda waller literally could care less about
whether they live or die only that eventually the
mission is completed so shotgun style she just
fires more and more bodies at a problem until it's
solved nathan fillion is hilarious as tdk you've
probably seen his powers detaching his limbs and
all the trailers i'm happy he finally made it into
another james gunn movie with his face visible he
did have a cameo scene in that first guardians of
the galaxy movie as the voice of this creature he
was supposed to have a bunch of big cameo scenes
and guardians of the galaxy 2 but they were cut
for time he's also technically the wonder man of
the mcu as well john cena is hilarious in the most
way possible as peacemaker exactly what he expects
he's been doing a bunch of comedy movies the last
couple of years so there's a lot of that energy
but because it's john cena and it's an r-rated
big war movie they have so much fun having him
just do so many so many bad things after seeing
him in this movie as this character i cannot wait
to see that peacemaker series that james gunn and
him are doing those episodes are supposed to start
in january so we'll probably get a trailer
for that sometime after the movie comes out
i will be doing full episode videos
for that idris elba is great in all
the stuff that he's done so no big surprises
that he tears it up his bloodsport in this
he was sort of cast as a replacement for will
smith's deadshot when he declined to come back
they didn't want to recast deadshot straight up so
that's why they made him bloodsport in the movie
but as you can see from all the trailers he's got
a lot of deadshot energy in this like they're both
gun themed sharpshooter villains and they're both
single dads trying to take care of their daughters
while at the same time being huge criminals margot
robbie's harley quinn is way more fun than she was
in her own birds of prey movie i feel like if you
had a lot of problems with the birds of prey movie
this movie has a little more fun with her
character in a little more traditional way
but there is no joker that comes along for the
ride with her and the movie itself does not need
the joker at all to make itself better so you will
not miss the joker during the events of this movie
but he is still alive i know people will be asking
all these joker questions after they see the film
like what's going on with him where is he at he's
still out there somewhere they haven't officially
killed him off in the dc eu yet even though there
are so many versions of the joker now you have to
consider the joaquin phoenix joker as if it's
happening in an alternate universe as you've
seen too there's a ton of smaller characters
like cd-list characters from the comics with
really notable actors or other marvel actors
playing them like michael rooker who's playing
savon he's great as always the movie uses him
in a kind of an unexpected way david dasmartian
from the ant-man movies you probably recognize
as polka dot man he's every bit as weird as you
would expect from the trailer scenes that they've
released of him but they do a good job of getting
you to care about him and i know a lot of you saw
all the trailers and you were like wait a minute
what a pete davidson and flula borg doing in this
movie like wait what what's going on here don't
worry there's a reason why their characters in
particular seem like they're such huge douchebags
like flula as a person is great you may remember
him from all of his youtube videos but he's
playing javelin a booster gold character booster
gold one of the biggest dc douchebags in the most
hilarious way possible so of course javelin
has a lot of energy in him too the movie deals
with both of their characters in really really
hilarious ways i wasn't really familiar with
daniela melchior before this movie she's playing
the second version of rack catcher from the comics
they're just calling her rat catcher too and the
name is just a joke about those c and d list comic
book characters where they were too lazy to create
a more unique name so they would just add like a
number to the end of the original name like two
or three she did a great job in this movie even
though her power's controlling an army of rats
and that seems kind of gross in the same way james
gunn got you to care about the talking tree and
the talking raccoon it feels like there's nothing
too gross or too weird the james gunn can't get
you to care about it just in general i was happy
with the way they ended the movie they do wrap
up most of the story lines from this movie in a
good way but also leave it in a way that allows
for them to do sequels with another version of
the team if james gunn wants to come back and do
another one like i said there are two post-credits
scenes so do stay after the credits just like
guardians of the galaxy movies one of them is
a funnier one and the other one sets up the next
big project so if you have seen the movie please
do not post spoilers for the post credit scenes
in the comments i will do a full easter eggs video
breakdown videos post credit scene video after the
official release date next week once you do have
a chance to see it though post all your movie
reactions in the comments below just overall it
did feel like a really solid dc movie though i've
got a couple other new trailer videos from this
week that i'm still working on in a new marvel
what if video that i'll post tomorrow you may
have seen they just released the first look of ben
affleck's batman in the flash movie you can click
here to watch that and click here for my brand
new marvel shanxi trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!